you see that speed difference what that
is
crazy is the new m1 ipad pro worth 200
more than the ipad air well today we
will find out because we're gonna
compare
everything from the differences in the
displays the both the quality and the
pro motion on the ipad to the speakers
the design
face id versus touch id and of course
the performance between the m1 chip
and the a14 we're also going to do a
comparison video between
all of the ipads so if you guys want to
see that click that subscribe button
down below
and help us reach 1 million subscribers
before the end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it now
looking at
the front as i'm holding these the one
thing that you will notice
is that the bezel is slightly larger on
the ipad air
that's because as a 10.9 inch display
compared to 11 inch i think apple just
did that
to differentiate them flipping over to
the back of the ipads you guys could see
that the ipad pro has a much bigger
camera bump
that's because instead of just a
standard camera we have a higher quality
standard
and an ultra wide and along with that we
have that
lidar scanner which is very useful for
augmented reality applications
and we also have a flash right there
which could be handy for scanning
documents
now as far as the weight and the
thickness they are basically identical
they're the same
bodies but one difference you could see
here is that the speaker girls
look different now we have some major
differences and we'll be doing a speaker
test in just a bit
but the ipad pro has less speaker
cutouts
but it's very interesting that they
actually have four speakers on the ipad
pro
two on each side compared to the ipad
air where there's actually only two
speakers one on each side so one of
these
are completely fake now as far as the
ports they look identical but
the ipad pro actually has a thunderbolt
port meaning it can go four times
as fast as far as performance and it can
actually connect to more devices
and one of the biggest differences
between these is touch id
versus face id the touch id button is
built in right here so in order to log
in
or use apple pay you actually have to
raise your hand and
touch your finger up at the top come on
there you go it just logged me in right
there
so i have used this for quite a while
and i gotta say that face id is
just way more convenient all you have to
do is tap on the screen
swipe up and you are logged in you don't
have to raise your hand
or flip the orientation anything like
that and it might seem like a little
thing and it really
is but you definitely enjoy the extra
convenience especially if you're using
it with a keyboard
where you just have to tap the space bar
and another big difference is the
cameras and now with the new m1 ipad pro
we don't have the same camera we have a
brand new one that can actually go
ultra wide which is crazy like this and
that allows
the new software to be able to reframe
your video get closer
a lot of cool extra features for face
timing and other apps and before we
compare the displays
let's test out the speakers as i
mentioned the ipad air
has four speaker girls and even more
speaker holes but it only has two
speakers so let's hear
how that compares to the ipad pro if you
have a pair of headphones put them on
and let's take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and i'll give you
guys my opinion
the ipad pro is definitely louder with
those extra two speakers and along with
that it has a better bass as well
the air still sounds good but it is on
the quieter side
and apple is leaving those quad speakers
to give you another reason to spend more
with the ipad pro and now let's compare
the displays now the actual image
sharpness or detail it's almost
identical
even this one just has a little bit of a
smaller display and reflectivity is also
very similar same coatings but apple did
limit the ipad air in terms of
brightness it maxes out at 500 nits
compared to 600 and because of that
difference you guys could see that not
only is it brighter
the highlights pop more as well because
600 nits
is what apple requires for hdr so the
ipad air cannot play
hdr videos in youtube whereas the ipad
pro can and you guys see
how the image just pops so much more and
then if you're using them in bright
rooms that extra
brightness does help just a little bit
now the biggest display difference has
to be
the 60 hertz versus 120 hertz pro motion
display refresh rate
and that is noticeable in a number of
ways the first way
even here at the desktop when we're
moving through uh once you're used to
the 120
hertz that's ultra smooth the 60 hertz
just seems a little bit slow a little
bit laggy as you guys could see
with our slow motion footage and along
with that you can also
really notice it on websites if you're
reading everything is just so much
smoother and the screen itself is more
responsive
as well and if you're somebody that
wants to use an apple pencil to draw to
write
that 120 hertz allows apple pencil to
have just
nine milliseconds of delay you guys are
looking at some slow motion footage but
to the eye
you literally don't see any delay
whatsoever
now apple doesn't officially state the
latency for the ipad air
but you could tell that it is not as
smooth there is a little bit of a delay
it's not a deal breaker but you can tell
the difference
and now it's time to compare the
performance we have
a few different benchmarks an ssd test
and real world tests as well i'm gonna
start out with geekbench five and as you
guys can see we have the a14 here with
four gigs of ram
compared to the crazy m1 with eight
gigabytes of ram and i'm gonna start out
with the cpu test and bm we have a
result
and this is crazy still doesn't stop
amazing me
how high the m1 ipad pro scores that's
almost identical to the macbook pro with
the fan
we have 7 300 compared to 4180 on
multi-core
that is a difference of 75
so way better performance on the single
core it's definitely closer when we have
a difference about eight percent
and with that said even though the ipad
pro is an absolute beast
the a14 is a powerhouse it is still
better than any other tablet out there
other than apple's own tablet so even
samsung's best gets smoked by the a14
but i can't wait to test it out
with real world performance now before i
move on i do want to go ahead and run
the compute test we're going to run
metal to see the graphics performance
and here we go
that is a huge difference in score
now the a14 with the ipad air it
actually beats out the previous ipad
pros
so it is a great performer but of course
the 8 graphics cores in the m1 scores
about 72 higher in terms of
graphics performance so apple is right
the m1 is literally
supercharging the ipad and next i want
to see how the middle score
translates to gaming performance so i
have the new wildlife
extreme benchmark here i'm going to
enable the unlimited
4k mode the ipad pro flew through that
test and we have 29.2 frames per second
so let's wait for the ipad air and it is
finished and
look at that score difference we have 2
355 compared to 484
and fps going from 29.2
down to 14.1 now that is very
interesting because
in the metal test we had a difference
about 72 percent
uh between these but when it goes to
gaming the difference is bigger
this one is literally double the frames
per second slash
actually slightly more than double the
next thing that i'm really curious about
are the ssd
speeds did apple put a much faster
uh storage chip in the pro model so i
have jazz
disc bench here we're going to go ahead
and run all of the tests
do you see that speed difference what
that is
crazy all right it is true apple did
[ __ ] the ssd the storage chip on the
ipad air
as far as the right speed we have 589
compared to
1532
crazy massive difference a random test
and the latency is also much faster in
terms of
write performance as far as read the
ipad pro is faster but it's not that big
of a difference
but i can't believe that the write speed
is so much
faster with the ipad pro and i think
that also has something to do with the
m1 chip of course we have
a lot more ram in there it's basically
the same chips that go into the macbook
airs the mac
pros the new imacs it's all on that
package compared to
a system that is designed uh as a tablet
or even
basically as a phone same a14 that's in
the phone here i have
50 42 megapixel raw images
opened up all of these have a bunch of
corrections already applied
so these are all edited which means
there's a lot more work that has to
happen
uh when you're opening up and switching
between them and they're all stored
locally on the machine not in the cloud
so these are full
files and as far as responsiveness i'm
expecting both of these to be
very good you guys see how quickly they
open up right there
and let me go ahead close that let's try
to zoom in here on this hot air balloon
man both are great now one thing you
guys commented in my ram video
is that apple has not yet updated ipad
os
to take advantage of the extra ram so
right now
this ipad is actually being limited and
hopefully here in a couple weeks in wwdc
we'll actually see some updates to that
but with that said i want to go ahead
and select
all 50 of these edited images and i'm
going to run an
export test i'm using standard
sharpening 90
quality and full size as well not the
default small size
and here we are rendering so it's been
two minutes so
far and i don't want to reveal how far
we've gotten i will just say that i'm
surprised
i thought that because limer hasn't been
updated ipad os hasn't been updated we
don't have the optimizations yet for the
ipad pro
the difference wouldn't be this big but
it's pretty significant all right guys
this test is finally
over both are now finished the ipad pro
with the m1 took
three minutes and 24 seconds
go ahead and guess and comment down
below how long
the ipad air took take a second
pause this video right now go and
comment down below i want to hear your
guys's thoughts
with that said three minutes 24 seconds
the ipad air took seven minutes and
pretty much seven minutes and one second
seven minutes and ninety
six point nine six so 701
more than twice as long and that was
really shocking to me like i said
ipad os is not yet optimized there's
more optimizations to be how there's
more ram available to be used
right now it's capped the 8k can't be
fully used and
with that in a geekbench we saw a cpu
difference of about 75
here it is over 200 over 100 percent
basically more than
double the performance in real world use
i was thinking maybe like
30 faster usually it's less than the
benchmarks
and then the re in the gaming test
compared to geekbench
we saw double the performance as well so
that is
very interesting now the last thing that
i want to do
is open up lumafusion which is video
editing
and see what kind of a difference we get
there so here i have opened a 4k
project it's just over four minutes long
this is from my vacation
and here i have footage with some
different let's apply
some different effects some re-timing
and as far as smoothness for most of it
it's almost identical and to be honest i
thought it was going to be
identical throughout the whole thing
because both these shapes are very
powerful
and if we're going ahead and skipping
through everything looks great
but i did notice that here where it had
4k
60 and if i hit play here
here i can tell and i don't know if you
guys could tell from above
that we have slight stuttering and frame
drops on the ipad air
whereas the ipad pro is perfectly smooth
can you guys see that difference
i don't think it's just the display with
pro motion
you actually see a little bit of frame
drop but it's only this specific 4k
60 clip with these effects other than
that
both these do a great job for 4k editing
and
luma fusion now what i want to do next
is go ahead and
grab this four minute and nine second
project and i'm going to
export it we have 4k 30 with 50 megabits
per second
let's select our file and
bam we are off all right guys look at
that the ipad pro is
almost finished here bam
that is incredible three minutes and
three seconds
for that project with a bunch of effects
let's go ahead and wait
for the ipad air and bam the ipad air is
now finished so we have
three minutes and three seconds compared
to five minutes
and one second so not twice as fast as
in the photo editing
but close to that and it's interesting
because
this is using the dedicated encoders on
both of these chips
not just the raw cpu and the graphics a
lot of times when you're using these
encoders
the difference is minimal but even here
we have a difference
of you know almost twice as fast with
apps that aren't really even optimized
yet so that
is really mind-blowing to me like i said
i was not expecting to see that big of
a difference with all of those tests
finished
what is the final verdict well the ipad
pro costs 200
more than the ipad air we have 600
compared to 800 at least based off msrp
of course we have links in the video
description
where we have sales on these so you guys
can check out the price
when you're watching but is it worth
spending 200
more to get the ipad pro after all these
tests
yes absolutely not only do you get the
better brighter display
that can play hdr that has the 120 hertz
you get way better cpu performance way
better graphics performance
even now when these just launched before
ipad os gets updated before apps get
updated
that was a massive difference of course
you guys heard the speaker differences
we have face id which is a lot more
convenient than touch
id what else pretty much everything is
better the wider cameras the higher
quality cameras
the thunderbolt port that's four times
as fast and more capable
i mean for 200 bucks you know previously
it was worth it you know in my opinion
but now with the m1
and the other updates this is a massive
difference
so with that said i have links down
below to both of these i have a couple
great videos right over there eight gig
for 16 gig for the ipad pro
we have the difference between the
larger one with the micro led screen
and click that circle above if you guys
want to subscribe and help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers before the
end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it there's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
you